you had this amazing career from TV now
you're going back to your roots yeah
well you know I started off as a
stand-up and I wanted to get back on the
road with the fam hey Rochelle what you
been up to man just chillin that's where
the electricity and
all we really are is just an
accumulation of every bad thing that's
ever happened to us before today I don't
remember when I got my television show
picked up I remember when it was
canceled I just remember the bad stuff
ah I gotta get off the road it's killing
me Michael's pilot is getting hot why
didn't you tell me while I was gonna
tell you but I know how depressed you
are when you come off the road he
doesn't get be happy for you are you yes
no you should open for Howie Howie
Mandel loves you you think the who opens
for air supply how he is the boo maybe
your other who last time I pitched it a
network they said yes my man you come to
work on the Jack Taylor show co-host
audience warm-up guy want me to be your
fluffer jack rather kill myself who
wants jelly belly Wow the contest winner
um I'm actually is the winner how long
you been living in my house three and a
half years 41 months that less than 39
fears and smaller it's less
no he's certified he's a working sir
he's our doctor fifty dollars and he's
certified
baby come how he is dying to work with
you I'm just not the headspace to do
this you don't have to dance for these
clams but you're gonna have to dance for
me if you're miserable on the road why
do you keep going out there I think it's
just all I know we got going here uh-uh
hearing impaired this guy's not cracked
a smile the whole night why isn't he
laughing I can't meet you thought I have
anxiety about flying with dogs i get a
service Pelican hey once you meet
Gilligan my service Pelican can we
switch seats I'm good